おはようございます
はじめしゃちょーです
只今朝の
５時８分でございます
えー只今トミックさんちに泊まってるんですけども
いつも通りトミックさんは今日もぐっすり寝ています
で、トミックさんは朝が弱いので今日も
まぁ、今日もいつものように「はじめくん良かった起こしてネ！」って言ってくれたんで
このスーパー早起きの僕に
今日はね、もうねちょっといつもと違う感じにトミックさんを起こしてあげようと思います
ちょっと今回はさすがに今までとレベルがちがうんで
ちゃんと近隣のあの確認はしっかりバッチリな状態で取ってるので
安心してくださいネ！
トミックさんのパジャマです（ワクワク）
いくぜ★
～♫
ズッ
（ガタッガン）～♫
（ゴンガタッ）～♫
～♫
（キリッ！）
（音楽が変わる）～♫
～♫
（パチッ）～♫
（ニヒッｗｗ）
～♫
カメラセットＯＫ！
寝顔くそわろたｗ
（ひそひそ）
（キランッ☆彡）
ふぅ～
３、２、１
じゃーん（音低い）
うっ、うっ、うっーΣ(ﾟДﾟ)
うっ、うっ、うっー！Σ(ﾟДﾟ)（リピート）
ぞわーん
うー、うー、うーー！Σ(ﾟДﾟ)
ギャァァー！Σ(ﾟДﾟ)
ゾン存ぞん...（銅鑼）
はぁは！
おはうようございますｗｗ
（笑いが止まらない）ｗｗ
おはようございますｗ
（はじめ）どうでしたか？ｗ
（トミック）お前まじでやまろよぉ
ふざけんなお前ｗｗ（はじめ爆笑ｗｗ）
え？このドッキリのための？（銅鑼）
（はじめ）そうですよ×２
（トミック）なにそれぇ～ｗ
（はじめ）どうでした？×２
（トミック）え、び、びっくりした
（はじめ）あははははは！
（トミック）あははじゃねーよｗ
と言うう訳で今日もトミックさんを
無事起こせました！（キリッ！）
～♫
（トミック）ははぁ、うそでしょ
（はじめ）ほんとですよｗ
（トミック）やばっ！
（はじめ）トミック、「ありがとう！」はー？
（はじめ）まぁでも、起きれましたよね今日も
（トミック）まぁまぁちゃんと起きれたよ
（はじめ）良かった×２